it's my very great uh pleasure today to
introduce my friend colleague Dr Greg
Sadler
um and uh um Greg you'll need to fill in
some of the of the gaps but you received
the doctor at
um
published uh extensively uh in onsong
and in philosophy of religion and he's
made a name for himself in two areas
especially
um one uh in um
actually in three areas and you can add
to them if I'm skipping some one is that
he is uh one of the leaders in uh using
philosophy in regard to counseling and
in regard to corporate management and in
regard to corporate ethics he does uh
extensive consultation in that respect
so we always tell our graduate students
you can in fact make a living in the
real world with a philosophy PhD and in
fact Greg is a stellar example of that
number two he is one of the leading
lights in uh bringing stoicism into
discourse today ever since um Admiral
Stockdale talked about how the study of
epicity this helped him as a prisoner of
war in Vietnam people have been
realizing that stoicism is not just a
word for what you do when you're sitting
at the dentist chair but it actually is
a way of living
and can have a lot to tell us today
about a living and and dealing with
adversity and living a good life and so
um uh by means of the stoicon and
various online Publications uh Greg has
been a leader in bringing people
together in that way and lastly if you
uh go to YouTube and and Google nearly
any philosopher
you will find somebody here who gives a
little lecture and then maybe has 20
hits and maybe you'll find a a
philosopher uh uh he's written some
Publications giving a talk and maybe
that person gets 50 hits
and then you'll find Greg Sadler and his
Talks on YouTube get thousands and
thousands and thousands of hits why well
if you watch them you'll see why he is a
master teacher and uh and a very
profound thinker and so he is uh
attracting a Renown and uh and fame uh
in that respect as well we're very very
lucky that he's living in Milwaukee now
and that he does some teaching for us
and that he is part of our community of
those here in Milwaukee that are
interested in nation philosophy so
please fill in your your CV if I've
missed any uh key points uh but I'm very
very uh um happy to introduce today uh
Dr Greg Sadler is going to be speaking
about virtue without the meme oh and
that that was uh probably one of the
nicest uh introductions that I've
I've had so that's really that's awesome
um yeah I mean I should I should mention
that um I'm not actually a stoic as such
I'm like a ciceronian eclectic but I do
do a lot of things with stoicism and
um this particular
set of topics that I'm working on I'm
working on with a friend and colleague
of mine Harlem Harold coveley I almost
called them Harold Oslo he's in Oslo and
he's a graduate student we're both very
interested in ancient philosophy and the
notion of the will and you know virtue
ethics and stuff like that
and so we're thinking this is going to
turn into a publication eventually and
I'm kind of looking for
the stuff that doesn't make sense so you
know if you have questions and you're
like yeah I don't get that that's
perfect that's exactly what we're that's
the kind of feedback we're looking for
um what I've got here is kind of uh
excursis through the history of ancient
philosophy and it's rooted in something
uh contemporary you know as Owen was
saying
there is a lot of contemporary interest
in stoicism today it's been going on you
could say there's like a kind of
Renaissance that's been happening for
the last you know 40 50 years in
Academia and in more popular venues you
could say
um
maybe 20 years or so 15 years or so
um and so you know like stoicon is part
of that which is coming up soon stoic
week all these more popularly oriented
things
and you know when we think about virtue
ethics traditions in in modernity oh
thank you
um
you know it's usually Neo Aristotelian
stuff that we're looking at you know to
think about Aleister McIntyre and the
the massive influence that you know he's
had since after virtue and that's that's
great you know I think that's that's
really awesome
um but as Anthony long points out in
Greek ethics after McIntyre and the
stoic community of reason
stoicism could actually provide a rival
tradition to aristotelianism it has a
lot of the same it offers a lot of the
same features that McIntyre is
highlighting and McIntyre also gets
stoicism wrong in after virtue and in
other things and so long you know kind
of takes him to task on that so I think
it's really worth giving
um some some close and studious
attention to Classic stoic virtue ethics
if we want to try to use it in the
present and then when we do that if
we're not you know just resting with
popularized accounts or stuff like that
which are fine they have their place and
we actually start going back to the text
that we have we find that there's
aspects of stoic virtue ethics that are
perhaps less attractive they're they're
problematic they're paradoxical and
we're like what the hell's going on here
you know and so that's part of what
we're going to be exploring here there's
I'm kind of conflicted about what to
call this I'm I use the word
official Doctrine or official position
as if there is one for ancient stoicism
and it has some some interesting
features that make it quite a bit
different than Aristotelian virtue
ethics you know if we think about what
Aristotelian virtue ethics has it's
really centered around this notion of
the mean right the mean between two
different opposed vices or sometimes
four different opposed vices like in the
case of anger five if you added the
udamian ethics and then two on the other
side
but there's like a mean position and
it's a mean with respect to actions and
with respect to passions or emotions and
external goods and stuff like that and
when you look at the stoic official
position it's not like that at all and
they actually say no no the
aristotelians have it wrong
so I think that we can make an
interesting uh examination of this and
I'd like to you know suggest something
that's coming out of these texts at the
start we should think about whether the
stoic position
is just paradoxical or as Cicero has
Cato saying startling truths
admonerobilia right or whether Plutarch
is right and the stoics are caught up in
actually self-contradictions that their
their position ultimately doesn't make
sense uh the Latin for that is wonderful
it's a de stoicorum repugnantius right
so their their doctrines are pushing
each other away they're they're
repugnant to each other so the the plan
that I had for this is to set out the
official stoic position
um or you know the classic stoic
position on virtue and vice and then
look at some of the arguments that the
stoics actually provide because they're
they're really big on on giving
arguments and then examine a few critics
some of the the most important ones and
so that would be Cicero himself who
first presents the stoic position and on
the ends book three in the mouth of Cato
one of the you know greatest stoics and
then tries to demolish it in book four
Plutarch Plutarch is a very prolific
ancient Middle platonist writer he's got
a number of different places where he's
attacking the stoics
another person is uh you know because we
don't want to leave the aristotelians
out Alexander aphrodisius and I thought
if we have the time we'll also briefly
look at the handbook of stoicism that we
now think is al-qinois for a while there
was some debate about who who actually
wrote that and I do actually have a
suggestion that we'll hopefully get to
at the end which is that maybe what we
have to adopt if we want to hold on to
this stoic position is something like
what Lawrence Becker in a new stoicism
one of the very important early books in
the stoic Renaissance in the 20th
century argues for which is a he calls
it a postedonian stoicism and if you
know who posedonius is
he's somebody who the official or
Orthodox stoics thought wasn't
sufficiently stoic right they they
attack him
um we don't unfor unfortunately we don't
have any of posedonius's works we just
have fragments but we also don't know
anything about these official stoics
because they weren't as important as as
posedonius so
where can we get the stoic official
Orthodox position
we're a little bit handicapped you know
if it'd be really great if like at these
you know herculin am sight Scrolls if we
find some things by crucipus or you know
clanthis these things that we only know
about from listings
um but we do have uh three fairly
systematic summaries of stoic Doctrine
Cicero and on the ends book three
diogenes liertes in book seven and Aries
didymus's epitome of stoic ethics which
you'll sometimes see referred to
mistakenly as stobeis it is found in
stobius's anthology but it's just one of
many texts in there
and it's important to point out too that
none of these are actually stoics Cicero
is not a stoic uh areas didymus is not a
stoic and
um
uh diogenes laertasis I mean he's more
attracted to epicureanism than anything
else so what are the features of stoic
ethics there's a lot of them and I want
to like just mention a few that we're
not going to talk about before talking
about the ones that we will go into so
one of them is that virtue has
understood as knowledge episteme but
it's also understood as Techni
um that I think we can leave aside for
the timing it's a very interesting topic
but I don't think we have to worry about
it there's also this question of the
unity of the virtues also very important
but
not that germane to this
um it is good to point out that the
stoics recognize four cardinal virtues
very similar to the epicureans the
platonists right there's wisdom Justice
Temperance courage and each of them is
sort of like a bucket that contains a
bunch of sub-virtues right so something
like generosity could be under justice
as as it is for for Cicero and then the
stoics themselves had this uh I mean
there was nothing they wouldn't debate
with each other one of the debates that
they had which is very interesting
if you if you're virtuous and you gain
virtue can you lose it
right it's sort of like the debates that
you see in Christianity like once saved
always saved
um the stoics themselves were on
different sides of that so what are the
features that we are interested in the
ones that pertain to Virtue and and
means the first is the idea that there's
nothing good or bad between the good or
the bad just what what the stoics call
indifference and so you could look at
that as kind of like a mean a middle
thing between them but it's not quite
the same thing the second makes it even
stronger there for the for the Orthodox
stoic position there is no intermediary
there's no middle there's no mean
between virtue and vice so that means
that every single one of us is either
virtuous or we're vicious and from the
stoic perspective I won't speak for any
of you but I would be vicious because
I'm not completely virtuous I'm not a
sage you know
uh the third one is that virtues unlike
the Aristotelian position and the later
plateness position because you know
there's they're happy to pick up on this
idea as a matter of fact Plutarch at one
point will anachronistically attribute
the doctrine of the mean to Socrates
pretty implausibly the stoics don't have
the doctrine of the mean
virtues are not middle positions between
vices in respect to particular subject
matters particularly with respect to
emotions as as we're going to see and
then the other thing that really
clinches it is this uh doctrine that is
so wild that it gets called the stoic
Paradox goods and bads are equal meaning
everything that's good is equally good
to any other thing that's good and
everything that's bad is equally bad so
what does that mean if you're virtuous
you're exactly the same amount of virtue
as somebody else who is virtuous and you
can't become more virtuous
so that's very different than you know
most virtue ethics that we think about
and you could say wow if if that's the
case then
how the hell are we actually going to
like progress in virtue and and the
stoics say well you're not going to or
at least some of them do
um
so we we should you know I should
mention well what is the good for the
stoics
um virtue and the virtues that's the
good so but that's not all that there is
because they also talk about what
participates in virtue
so good actions participate in virtue
right they're stemming from virtue good
conditions which include certain
activities or propensities those those
would be good good emotional states
the stoics don't think that all emotion
is bad as a matter of fact they had the
euphi the good emotions and they
distinguished three main categories of
those which include a whole bunch of
other ones friendship Harmony those are
good things a friend is a good thing
good use of or dealing with matters
crisis in in Greek and um
Cato is going to say and this is Cicero
putting it in his mouth so we don't know
did Cato really think this I mean
probably
um all other philosophical systems and
varying degrees no doubt but still all
which reckon anything of which virtue is
not an element do not merely as I hold
give us no assistance or support in
becoming better people but are actually
corrupting to the character that's
that's I mean that's the official stoic
position so what does that mean about
aristotelians or platonists I mean the
the epicureans everyone knows they're
corrupting to the character everyone
bashes the epicureans but even the the
other schools that are kind of close ah
they're bad too because they've got the
wrong conception of virtue so if we look
at the first feature
uh the you know the stoics recognize and
I give you a hand out there about Goods
bads and indifference
um unlike the platonists or
aristotelians or later Christian authors
think about Augustine for example there
are there are no higher and lower Goods
for the stoics you have if something's
good it's good and that's it
um and there's you know different words
that are used in Greek the cologne in
Latin the honestum right this is the
category of things that are
intrinsically good and and that includes
the virtues and and these other things
everything else is just indifferent it
has some value but it the Greek word for
that oxia red has some sort of measure
of value but it's not the kind of value
that gets you to bad or good so some
indifference can be preferred or
rejected so you know for example
wealth is a preferred indifferent
poverty is a rejected indifferent but no
amount of money is ever going to make
you virtuous and no amount of poverty is
going to make you vicious or miserable
or bad or anything like that so diogenes
liertes says only the morally beautiful
is good virtue and whatever participates
in virtue can consist in this Seneca
will actually in letter 74 say
he's Seneca is a little bit willing to
use language of of goods in ways that
are
pushing the stoic thing he says the true
goods are those which reason bestows
substantial and eternal that cannot fall
away Northern nor can they grow less or
be diminished other things are Goods
according to opinion so everything that
like you know pleasure right
aristotelians that say pleasure is a
good nah that's only a good according to
opinion not a real good at all just
indifferent and so the stoics you know
they they do think that the indifference
have value in relation to each other so
diogenes of Babylon will say money is
good because you can use it to like
improve your health but health is still
an indifferent it's it's it's not virtue
or advice
and the stoics thought that indifference
do matter you know they reject what you
could call an indifferentism being
indifferent to the indifference is not
always a the way that you should behave
virtue is going to work within the realm
of the indifference but none of those
things ever cease to be indifference so
they are in between virtue and vice but
you should probably think of it as
they're not on the same plane virtue and
vicer up here or I mean you could put
Vice way to the hell down here if you
want to because it's bad and then you've
got this vast swath of things in between
that we we call these indifference
um and and you know Seneca will say
this is in letter 82 nothing is glorious
that does not involve indifference
illness pain poverty death none of these
are glorious in themselves but nothing
is glorious without them virtue meets
and handles them each object takes on a
splendor not its own when virtue is
added to it so virtue is the thing
that's that's good and then it applies
to these indifference
and interestingly moral Improvement
procope in Greek that is a preferred
indifferent according to these sort of
traditional summaries of stoic Doctrine
so that's our first feature right so
we've got one one key aspect then we go
a little bit deeper the second key
feature there's no intermediary between
virtue and vice this is clearly
different than the Aristotelian or later
platonic or other perspectives
every one of us according to this this
traditional way of looking at virtue is
either virtuous or vicious I don't I
can't speak for any of you I'm vicious
in that in that case because I'm not a
sage Aries didymus says there's nothing
in between there's no mataksu there's no
there's no in between in that case and
he says that uh it's the view of Zeno
and his stoic followers there's two
types Gene of human beings The Good the
spudion right as a term that you see in
Aristotle a lot as well and then the bad
the fall on and you're either one or the
other that's it there's no possibility
the good uh use the virtues throughout
their life the bad use
the vices or are used by them and then
diogenes laerte says between virtue and
vice there's nothing intermediate
whereas according to the parapathetics
there is and one what is this thing that
diogeny says is in between moral
Improvement
and that's a little bit different than
the traditional presentation in
Aristotle right we've got like
you know vicious people over here and
virtuous people over here and then you
know closer to The Virtuous would be the
self-control the you know people who
have encartia and then there's the
people who lack or lose self-control you
know they have acracia and if you do
that enough you become vicious right
there's like this whole area the the
stoic position and endogenes Laertes is
saying well the thing that we need to
think about is the in between as moral
Improvement
um and from the stoic perspective this
this perspective that we're looking at
here
even if you're improving you're vicious
so that's pretty different than nearest
Italian position
um
the third feature virtues not being
intermediate or mean States
there's a rejection of virtue here as a
mean between vices of excess and
deficiency particularly when it comes to
the emotions the stoics are very very
clear that the aristotelians are wrong
in construing virtue as what Hobbes will
later call a mediocrity of the passions
right and Leviathan he's bashing the the
aristotelians for for a different reason
because he wants to sweep them off the
uh the carpet so he can do his thing so
in Seneca is on anger with respect to
anger itself and then in Cicero's
tusculine disputations in books three
and four where he's presenting the stoic
view on the emotions and it largely
endorsing it maybe in a little less
clear aspect in Cicero's on duties book
one
um
uh courage you know winds up being a
virtue that applies to the emotions in
that book The stoics or at least the the
presentation of the Stokes is
you know moderate emotions are still bad
uh because they're they're passions
they're leading us astray so Seneca will
say in letter 85 virtue alone possesses
moderation the evils that afflict the
Mind do not admit of moderation
isn't that an interesting idea you can't
have the right amount of anger you can't
have the right amount of grief or fear
or sadness or desire and he says if you
give in to them they increase and they
lead to the vices so
there's a lot of emotional states that
are just kind of pushed aside
in the tuscular disputations
in book three Cicero says all
disturbance per tabatsio is a movement
to the soul either destitute of reason
or contemptuous of reason or disobedient
to reason that's that's the key thing
for the stoics this is why those
emotions are are problematic and so okay
we can buy that right what about the
other things that from an Aristotelian
perspective virtues apply to
actions proxies right can't those be
moderate or what about external Goods
like our wealth you know if we're going
to be generous
so the virtues do apply to the external
Goods for the stoics which we should use
and pursue and value prudently justly
courageously and temperately
um
but it's it's not the same position as
you know the Aristotelian point of view
in part because there's this heavy
emphasis on doing things rationally and
also there's no like in between the two
different sets of vices
now that said Seneca at times will talk
as if courage is
in between cowardice and foolhardiness
so that that seems kind of Aristotelian
right but for most of these other
virtues that's just not the case you've
got
um Justice you've got Injustice right
you've got wisdom Folly you've got uh
temperate Temperance or moderation and
then you've got in Temperance and
there's no mention of like you know a
spectrum or something like that that you
would you would fall into so the stoics
you know are pretty clear about that
that's the third feature
fourth feature goods and bads are all
equal to each other so there is some
controversy about this that we find in
diogenese Laertes where he says that you
know crucipus and ethical questions book
four and Perseus and Zeno think that all
wrong things yeah
hamartima sorry in that are are equal
but that heraclitis of Tarsus who's a
student of Auntie Potter who is you know
one of the skolarcs and Anthony Doris
both say no that's not the case so
there's already some in the the early
stoa there's some disagreement about
this but even by the time of Seneca so
we're talking about you know the late
Roman stoa he says virtue admits of no
stretching it can't extend any any
further once you've got virtue you've
got virtue
diogenes Laertes says that the stoics
think with Justice and Injustice there
isn't a more just or more unjust and
likewise with the other virtues so there
there isn't a more courageous and a less
courageous you either have courage or
you don't
Seneca um also says he attributes this
to Socrates Socrates used to say that
truth and virtue were the same just as
truth does not grow neither does virtue
grow so it has a it has due proportions
and it is complete
um Cicero has Cato tell us that virtue
and harmony with reason and unbroken
constancy is one nothing can be added to
it to make vert make it virtue in a
greater degree and nothing can be taken
away and the name of virtue still left
it so yeah this is pretty I mean we
could multiply other citations but I
think you get the idea right there there
isn't any growth in in virtue that's
that's all that you you've got
um likewise Vice if you're vicious
you're just vicious and that's it you
know
now the stoics give some arguments about
these matters and I thought we could you
know briefly talk about some of those
that may be interesting to come back to
some of these and you'll notice some
familiar
tropes coming up in them as you look
through them so
when it comes to Virtue and the
indifference
Cato says and Cicero is on the ends the
light of a lamp is eclipsed and
overpowered by the Rays of the Sun a
drop of Honey is lost in the vastness of
the Aegean Sea an additional six pence
is nothing amidst the wealth of creasius
or a single Step In the Journey from
here to India so those you know you get
the idea there right you're not going to
have any way of seeing it if the stoic
definition of the ends of goods be
accepted it follows that all the value
that you set on bodily advantages must
be absolutely eclipsed and annihilated
by the Brilliance and Majesty of virtue
right so the idea there is you add
anything to Virtue you're not going to
notice any you know tangible difference
because it's already as good as it's
going to be Seneca has a similar thing
just as the Supreme good does not admit
of increase exactly the happy life
cannot be increased either for it is not
without the Supreme good men do not
understand that the happy life is a unit
for it's its Essence and not its extent
that establishes such a life on the
noblest plane
similar kind of idea there as to nothing
being in between virtue and vice
diogenes Laertes again tells us that
crucipus
was was presenting this if one truth is
not more true than another neither is
one falsehood neither is one falsehood
more false than another in the same way
one deceit is not one is not more deceit
than another nor sin than sin right so
he's got three different classes of I
guess you could say bads there and
they're all equally bad and he brings up
he who is a hundred furlongs from
canopus and he who's only one Furlong is
equally not in canopus so you know if
we're here in Milwaukee and we have to
go to Waukesha uh drive down Wisconsin
Avenue you make it 10 blocks now we
would say you are closer to Waukesha
from the stoic perspective you could be
at the off ramp you know to get on uh
164 or something like that you're not in
Waukesha yet and it doesn't make any
difference right Cicero has this other
one just as a drowning man is no more
able to breathe if he'd be not far from
the surface of the water so that he
might at any moment emerge than if he
were actually at the bottom just as a
puppy on the point of opening its eyes
is not less blind than one just born
similarly a person who's made some
progress towards the state of virtue is
nonetheless in misery uh than he who's
made no progress at all so
you know you can make progress if you
want to but it's not going to do you any
good you're still equally vicious you're
still just as bad you're still just as
miserable
um
here's another one I'm not going to go
through all of these because I do want
to have plenty of time for a discussion
but so you know Cicero says and on the
ends just as supposing the Merit of a
shoe were to fit the foot many shoes
would not be superior to few shoes or
bigger shoes to smaller ones I mean in
that case they wouldn't fit right but he
doesn't worry about that so in the case
of things the good of which consists
solely in propriety and opportunist a
larger number of these things will not
be rated higher than a smaller number
nor those lasting longer to those of a
shorter duration so these these things
that we can measure they just don't
matter to Virtue according to to the
stoics
Seneca has I'll just read one more from
Seneca that I particularly like
whether you draw a larger or smaller
Circle its size affects its area not its
shape one Circle May remain as it is for
a long time while you may contract the
other or even merge it completely with
the sand in which it was drawn but each
circle had the same shape that which is
straight is not judged by its size or
number or duration it can no more be
made longer than it can be made shorter
scale Down The Honorable life as much as
you like from the full hundred years
reduce it to a single day it is equally
honorable sometimes virtue is widespread
governing kingdoms cities and provinces
creating laws developing friendships
regulating the duties that hold between
relatives and children so you know
you're a States person you're doing all
these cool things right at other times
it's limited by the narrow bounds of
poverty Exile or bereavement your life
has shrunk down to a studio apartment
that you never leave or something like
that and yet your virtue is exactly the
same as that person who's living the
living a large life you know at least
according to the stoics he says virtue
is just as great even when it's
retreated into itself and is shut in on
all sides for its spirit is no less
great and upright it's suggestity no
less complete it's Justice no less
inflexible there he's mentioning courage
magnaminity
um you know wisdom and and Justice he's
using those as examples
so you know this is a you know pretty
coherent do we buy it I mean I don't
um and I think a lot of other people
would have a hard time with it
but that is the official stoic position
and in an Antiquity there were you know
a lot of people who are like well this
clearly can't be right among them are
people from other schools so we have
Cicero Cicero isn't a stoic he's he's an
Eclectic officially he belongs to the
academic skeptic school but he's he's
really not that skeptical about a lot of
things he accepts a lot of stoic ethics
accepts a lot of Aristotelian stuff
actually makes an argument at one point
that is is kind of implausible that the
the stoics on the one hand and the
plateness and and aristotelians on the
other are really saying the same thing
with just with different language
um I don't think that's that's all that
defensible but he he does try to claim
that in in book four and then we have
the platonic tradition right Plutarch is
probably the most important of the
middle platonists in that respect
Plutarch actually has a book on stoic uh
self-contradictions where you'd expect
to see some arguments and then he's got
other ones as well like um
uh on the common Notions against the
stoics okay so obviously he's going to
be combating them
um I think that you know there's there's
a few things in Al qinus's Handbook of
platonism that
you know makes sense here and then
Alexander vathrodisius and I should
point out that in the latter two the
stoics are not named as such it's they
say those people say but the only people
who say those things that they're
criticizing are the stoics well I guess
you could also say aristos who the
stoics themselves criticize and I guess
maybe the cynics might be interpreted as
saying that but it's really mostly the
the stoics and there are other people
who criticize the stoics platinus
criticizes the stoics but it's not
really about the virtues as such it's
more metaphysical issues
sexist empiricus and against the
ethicist criticizes the stoics and in
some of his other works but on virtue
not not quite so much so it's really as
far as I can tell
those four are the
the main ones that we'd want to look at
so what does Cicero say in book three
um of onions uh Cicero has Cato present
the stoic position and then like a good
academic he attacks it in book four as a
matter of fact that's what's really cool
about on the ends is first it's the
epicureans and then critique of the
epicureans then the stoics critique of
the stoics and then finally book five is
the Aristotelian slash platonic position
as Cicero is is presenting it so Cicero
says
um if you buy into this idea that all
peoples Folly Injustice and other vices
are alike and all sins are equal and
that those who by nature in training
have made considerable progress towards
virtue unless they've actually attained
to it our AB are utterly miserable and
there's nothing whatever to choose
between their existence and that of the
wickedest of mankind so that the great
and famous Plato supposing he was not a
wise man live no better and no happier a
life than any unprincipled scoundrel and
he takes that to be an absurdity right
obviously Plato is better than some
rumdum off the street who's like you
know breaking into cars stealing
stealing radios or something like that
right
um well how is that the case then given
this stoic view he also attacks that
whole outshines argument that we looked
at he says with things so small as to be
eclipsed from view we are bound to admit
it makes no difference to us whether we
have them or not on the other hand with
things that are not so completely
eclipsed it may nevertheless be the case
that any difference they do make is not
very great bodily Goods resemble
resemble ladder the rather the latter
sort of things they contribute something
not not a lot but something so if you're
you know if you're happy because you're
virtuous but you're also you know
independently wealthy
that does make a little contribution
it's better that I mean sort of like
what Aristotle said right you can have
the virtues but if you are destitute
you're not happy right I mean the stoics
would say no you are happy
but you can be a little bit happier well
nothing Stokes wouldn't say that Cicero
would say that as as a refutation
um another one that he says Zeno himself
maintains that Plato if he's not wise is
not in the same case as the Tyrant
Dionysus the guy who like held Plato up
right Dionysus what's the difference
Dionysus has no hope of wisdom he's
never going to be any better whereas
Plato can improve
so this is an argument against them and
then finally he says that the stoics
bring forth forward what gets
translators extremely false analogies
similar to Denise dissimulus right so
similarities that are not similar
likenings that are not not alike and he
says that you infer that Improvement in
progress in virtue are of no avail to
save a man from being entirely wretched
until he's actually arrived at virtue
there's like a threshold that you have
to cross and he says Cato there's no
analogy between progress and virtue and
the cases you're describing in which
however one advances the situation one
wishes to escape from Remains the Same
until one has actually escaped from it
and he says good analogies would be this
instead one's eyesight is dim another is
General Health is weak apply remedies
and they get better day to day
so you know I mean think about this I
can't you're all just blurs to me with
this this off but I put this this
technology on and now suddenly well I
can see you you know I I know who I'm
talking to to Owen rather than some some
guy who wandered him off the street
right now what if that was uh me
training my eyeballs or something like
that doing eye exercises well that would
be like becoming virtuous he says
similarly with all who earnestly pursue
virtue they get better their vices and
errors are gradually reduced so Cicero
is saying listen your analogies your
arguments they're not very good we
shouldn't buy into them Plutarch
um in in a number of texts is going to
go after them he the first one I wanted
to talk about is progress and virtue
right he's actually got this how a
person may be aware of their progress
and virtue now if you can be aware of
progress there has to be some sort of
like Criterion for it right so he says
those who do not adjust their tenets to
fit the facts pragma scene but rather
try to force the facts into an unnatural
agreement with their assumptions have
filled philosophy with a great number of
difficulties
of which the greatest is that it would
assign all human beings to a general
category of Badness with the single
exception of the absolutely perfect
person a result of which is to make a
puzzle of what we call progress in Greek
right actually progressing towards how
we ought to be and he says it it falls
but little short of the uttermost
foolishness and it represents people
who've been released by it from all
sorts of passions and weaknesses as
living in a state of equal wretchedness
with those who have not yet been freed
but from a single one of the the evils
in the stoic contradictions he says they
say that neither is a person perfect if
he doesn't have all the virtues nor a
deed perfect which is not done in
accordance with all the virtues but in
the sixth book of the more the ethical
problems crucifus says the decent person
is not always being courageous
uh nor is he intemperate all the time
either they make conflicting statements
when they say that he who has the
virtues or vices acts in accordance with
all of them at once and that the decent
person is not always being courageous in
the base person cowardly so that might
be you could probably argue your way out
of that and say well
you know you don't always have to be
using courage right but then he says
something uh else that I think is this
is an uncommon conceptions he says since
it is from the summit of progress that
people change to happiness and virtue
one of two things must be true
either progress is not a state of vice
and unhappiness or else virtue is not at
far removed from Vice nor is happiness
from unhappiness when the stoics refuse
to abandon any of the conflicting
propositions they've got a whole bunch
of like things that they're buying into
right
but wish to assert and maintain all them
together does it perhaps seem to you
that they're in an amazing way
confirming the consistency of their
doctrines and still more their deeds
when declaring that all who are not
sages are in the same degree vicious and
unjust and unreliable and foolish they
then again while avoiding and
abominating some to others and Trust
money or Handover offices and give their
daughters in marriage it is at odds with
the common conceptions to deal with some
people as tolerable and with others is
extremely vicious while subjecting all
alike to blame and reproach this is what
we call a performative contradiction
right so he's saying you're you're
you've got all these things that you're
committed to you can't actually live
this out your your conduct shows that
you don't really buy into this or if you
do buy into it it's because you stoics
are unwise
you you lack uh wisdom
um a little bit later he'll say you know
with progress and virtue
one important indication of progress is
that you no longer hold the opinion that
any one of your errors is unimportant
but your circumspect and hateful
regarding all right you treat each thing
as if it matters
um and then in on moral virtue he says
if by positing all errors and faults are
equal they're in some other way looking
the truth overlooking the truth this
present discourse is not the proper
occasion to confute them but in the case
of the emotions right so remember virtue
should be like a mean between the
emotions from the later plate nest and
the Aristotelian View
the stoics appear to be in opposition to
reason and contrary to plain evidence
for according to them every emotion is
an error and everybody who Grieves or
fears or desires is guilty of error
there need to be some great differences
in the emotions according to their
greater or lesser intensity akata
tomalon kaito hechon which he brings up
at a number of points it's often
translated as degrees right there's
degrees in virtue and vice and so he's
saying listen
um somebody could have the right amount
of fear and and he's quite right because
the stoics do think that you can have
the right kind of fear that's what
caution the good emotion that is
rational fear does so I think he's he's
on point with that
um
alkenous
taken by Dylan to be criticizing or
opposing the stoic view he um he he will
say that uh there's imperfect and
perfect virtues and this is kind of
interesting because
actually does agree that perfect virtues
are not subject to higher and lower
levels of intensity so once you have you
know Justice completely you're
completely just and and so that seems to
be a bit different than like Plutarch
his his fellow middle platonist and it
seems more like the stoics but then
elkinois he's kind of trying to have it
all he says
vices exhibit both increase and decrease
one person can be more foolish or unjust
than the other so that's kind of a an
interesting almost hybrid position
and then finally Alexander of
aphrodisius in ethical problems is going
to say the just and the unjust person
come to be either from the opposite or
what is intermediate they do not do so
from the opposite you know so The
Virtuous person doesn't come from the
vicious person
so there must be some sort of
intermediate between them and the
condition from which just and unjust
people come to be is intermediate
between them
the same argument applies to all virtue
and wickedness and then he's got a
clincher he says
they said the stoics wickedness was in
man's nature and all were born Wicked
well then wickedness would be natural
for us
right
um but the uh that of which the opposite
is natural for something is itself
unnatural for that so Justice and virtue
would be unnatural for us human beings
the stoics want to say no these virtues
are like are realized human nature so
this is this is a pretty good argument
right there
um he also says that this is in in
ethical problems 27
no one would say that a person who's on
the way to Virtue in in Greek is
characterized by a combination of virtue
and vice it doesn't work quite like that
it's got to be a separate State and then
finally an on fate according to them
virtue and vice are the only things that
are in the one case good in the other
bad and none of the other living
creatures are able to admit of either
and of human beings the greatest number
are bad or rather there are one or two
whom they speak of having become good
men as in a fable uh you know like the
Ethiopian Phoenix all the rest are
wicked and so to an equal extent so
there's no difference between one and
the other and all who are not wiser
alike mad if this is so
how will the human being not be the most
wretched creature of all having
wickedness and Madness innate within
them and allotted to them I think that's
a a pretty good argument you know right
there so you know we could say ah you
know the stoic official position it's
got some serious issues
could it be saved at all against these
sort of criticisms
so there's a couple ways but saving it
means
modifying it to some degree so diogenes
liertase
he says something really interesting
about posedonius and postedonius will
remember is a kind of eclectic
less Orthodox stoic it's criticized by
the stick in the model Orthodox stoics
of his time unnamed people
so posedonia says the proof the
technerion right the the like decisive
proof that virtue really exists is that
Socrates diogenes and antisthenes made
moral progress
so he doesn't point to their virtue he
points to the fact that they themselves
made progress towards virtue
Cicero and on the ends book three
um
he gives us something kind of
interesting from Cato the stoics deny
virtues or vices can be increased into
Greek in Latin right but they do believe
that each of them can be in a sense
expanded and widened in scope
fundi quota Moto at quasi de la tari
right so he said well what the hell's
the difference there you know well
presumably so you can't become more
virtuous in any like substantive sense
but the virtue could be like better
applied or you know more widely applied
or something like that
Seneca says in letter 66 there's many
aspects to Virtue they unfold themselves
as life varies and his actions differ
but virtue itself does not become less
or greater virtue is not changed by the
matter but if the matter is hard and
stubborn it doesn't make the virtue
worse if Pleasant and joyous it doesn't
make it better also in the same letter
he says they're going to be great
differences according as the material
varies as it becomes now broader now
narrower now glorious dealing with like
wonderful things maybe like a
commonwealth now base balancing your
checking account or something like that
right manifold and scope and now limited
so okay maybe there's something to this
right
um
Cicero will also talk about a five-part
development he's got like a schema that
that Cato presents where we first start
with like preserving ourself in our
being and our natural Constitution and
then we start you know retaining some
things in accordance with nature and
repelling other things and then third we
start to make proper choices uh
conditioned by what we translate as
duties or appropriate action kumaficio
celexio and then finally that choice
becomes a fixed habit perpetua and then
all of that is sort of Preparatory
finally we get to the point where these
choices become fully rationalized
Constance and in harmony with nature and
he says here the good properly so-called
arises and comes to be understood so
that there we become virtuous this is
how progress Works in one account and
and Seneca has a good thing to say too
you know and Seneca is kind of um
you know he wants to be a good Orthodox
stoic in this this respect but he also
seems to at some points
need to modify it so in letter 75
he says are there no degrees of
Happiness below your happy man is there
a sheer descent right so you're not
virtuous boom you're at the bottom he
says no
he who makes progress is still numbered
with fools so he's vicious right but
he's separated from them by a long
interval among the very persons who are
making progress there are great spaces
great intervals intervening they fall
into three classes and so the bottom
class are people who are beyond the
reach of many of the vices particularly
the great ones but not be on the reach
of all and he says not even these are to
be despised like the fools are to be
despised right
so yeah that would be you know those of
us who
lose our temper still or you know
um aren't generous when we're beneficent
when we should be or are tempted to be
unjust and every once in a while we
cheat on our taxes or something like
that tell little lies right and then he
says second those who've laid aside the
greatest deals of the mind and its
passions but are not in assured
possession of immunity they can they can
backslide so this would be sort of like
the Aristotelian and critic person
wouldn't it they they get things right
most of the time they kind of they still
gotta Force themselves to do the right
thing and if they slack off they're
probably going to go back down right and
then the first you know just below
virtue those who've not attained wisdom
but who have attained a place nearby
people who've laid aside all their
passions and vices and learn what things
are to be embraced but their Assurance
is not yet tested so they're they're
close but they're not all the way in
virtue Seneca seems to think that I mean
he does say they're all still you know
to be numbered among the fools but
they're not they're not foolish fools
right they're I don't know I mean we use
this sophomore right uh the Wise Fool
and in college things
um Epictetus
Epictetus is a very
different interests and kind of stoic I
I call them a conservative innovator
because he he is in some respects more
conservative than Seneca or Marcus
Aurelius but he also brings in lots of
Aristotelian stuff and he originates
other ideas in uh stoic Philosophy for
example bringing in the term proyracis
which you know it's found in other
places right but it's mostly an
Aristotelian idea and he like reworks it
into making it a absolutely central part
of of stoic philosophy and Epictetus
doesn't talk about virtue much so he's
different than the other stoics in that
respect
in 2.9 he says philosophers admonish us
not to be satisfied with merely learning
but to add practice and training for who
is there among us that cannot give a
philosophical discourse about Good and
Evil and the meaning we all know the the
story we all know the party line he says
it will run like this of things that are
some are good some are evil other others
indifferent now good things are virtues
and everything that partakes in the
virtues evil are the opposite well
indifferent our wealth health and
reputation and then he says now if
somebody interrupts Us in the middle of
this or laughs or something you know
there's a loud noise suddenly we don't
know what we're talking about anymore
right because what we have to do is
actually practice we have to we have to
make this part of ourselves
so how do we do that he's got a chapter
called on progress Perry prokopis
he says if it is virtue that holds out
the promise to create happiness and calm
and serenity assuredly progress towards
virtue is progress towards each of these
states in mind how comes it that we
acknowledge virtue to be a thing of this
sort and yet seek progress and make a
display of it in other things progress
isn't being able to read precipice he
talks about that at a number of points
oh you can you know you can rattle off
the stuff but you don't actually follow
the teachings he says are you not
willing to show him the work of virtue
so that he may learn to where to look
for his progress look for it where your
work lies what it Where does your work
lie and here he says three things
and desire and aversion in choice and
refusal and in giving ascent and giving
and withholding a cent of judgment now
these are what he talks about in another
chapter uh 3.2 the three Fields the
three topoi of stoic philosophy which
don't show up in anybody else's stoic
philosophy just in Epictetus right so
where is he getting this from oh we
don't know you know we're not sure at
all Seneca does talk about three Fields
but they're not the same three fields in
one of his letters but what are these
three Fields well desire and aversion at
the discipline of of Desire uh choice
and refusal which you know is is
covering action the discipline of action
and then the discipline of ascent so he
says you got to get those things right
and then you're actually going to be
virtuous
and then um he talks about
these three the third belongs only to
those who are making progress he uses
this word progress all the time
Epictetus is hammering away on this
in uh 2.3 he talks about the central
importance of priorases
he says what is by its very nature
capable of hindering prior racist
nothing that lies outside its fear only
itself when it's perverted through this
it becomes and these are the words that
he's using the only Vice the only virtue
so our proiracis our faculty of choice
you know which is self-determining and
free that is where virtue and vice lie
for Epictetus it that literally is the
only virtue and vice and he says that
doesn't mean that we have to despise the
other faculties you know does a person
say there's no use or advancement except
in the
um the prior racist no he's just
assigning it's do it's true value to
each thing and then the other thing that
Epictetus brings up that I think is
helping out here habit is absolutely
important right he talks about that all
the time he gives you clear advice about
how to change our habits how to
understand our habits that only makes
sense if
um we have a substantive concept of
making progress
now you know could we understand this as
like virtues like a threshold and you
have to make a certain amount of
progress before you can actually get
there and then cross that threshold I
think that's fine that that works but
the idea that
you know
nobody I mean except for the sage nobody
is virtuous
um although that is a you know
traditional stoic idea seems like a
non-starter you know and so we've got a
couple different options in the present
and then you know here's where we'll
wrap up and you know maybe have a little
conversation you know you could stick
with the official problematic position I
don't know why the hell you would want
to you know there may be aspects of it
that are that are worth
preserving but as a whole it doesn't
seem to be particularly useful and I
think a most contemporary stoics like
long well long as long actually says
that he's he's not a stoic he's an
Epicurean at some times in a skeptic at
sometimes in a stoic at other times
um but you know Becker and people like
that say that it's very important to
stress the importance of progress and to
not discourage people by saying you
can't ever be virtuous uh the other
thing we could do
would be to try to shoehorn stoic
philosophy into a more generic more or
less neoraristotelian virtue ethics I
think that's kind of a non-starter too
why do stoic ethics if it's exactly the
same as Aristotelian ethics why not just
do the Aristotelian ethics right or do
the debased forms that we find in in
popular presentations of of virtue
ethics that like make anything they want
into a virtue right so long as it's in
between
um even that doesn't even fit
Aristotle's notion of of things but I
think we could have a good happy medium
so maybe there is a mean here you know
some sort of thought through possibly
semi-eclectic perspective that
recognizes that there has to be progress
towards virtue and if it you know if we
don't want to say that it's like a
middle state where you got Vice here and
then virtue here and then this middle
state of progress maybe we do have to
have something like a threshold account
but maybe the threshold has to be way
closer
than this unattainable Sage idea that
was was being pushed you know and we
probably need some recognition I think
of improvement in virtue once we're
actually virtuous right so if that means
abandoning the official stoic position I
would say that you know Epictetus and
Seneca
maybe they're good models for that you
know it certainly seemed to be something
that posedonius and panatius were
you know at least receptive to so I
don't think that this is anti-stoic or
abandoning stoicism and such but and
here's what I'll I'll close if there's
going to be a robust stoic virtue ethics
as a rival tradition to Aristotelian
virtue ethics in the present as long as
suggesting in his article
um which I think is a great prospect
it's going to have to be a lot more
flexible when it comes to these these
understandings of virtue and that means
that there may in fact have to be a mean
smuggled back in in some respect
so that's that's all that I've got so
far
um I know I've talked for quite a while
uh and maybe you know
to the point where people have forgotten
what what was originally said but I'm
happy to take any questions or comments
or
thanks
so we have a couple we do not as usual
have the um
the online presence uh hooked up uh yeah
so Martin if you have any questions just
chime in otherwise we won't be seeing
you we're Jerry rigging it
but uh TJ do you have anything or
otherwise I think I think is it are you
muted
yeah I'm not hearing anything though
oh there we go
okay
do you guys have any questions or
I mean I covered this is kind of a wide
sweep through the history of
moral philosophy but yeah go ahead on
well
I'm going to try to bring them to get
the Aristotelian and the stoic ideas
together yeah
Aristotle says there's no mean of an
extreme right you can't uh be uh the uh
an adulterer in the right way with the
right woman at the right time not to
walk there maybe maybe every other
conference I go to whatever that doesn't
work yeah you likewise there's you know
mean for a virtue you can't be it makes
no sense to say he's too just or you
don't want to be too just you don't want
to be not just yeah yeah so by
definition the middle point is somehow
unique yeah yeah but aerosol stresses
that it's not a matter of precision it's
not a matter of mathematical yeah so
let's think of a rather trivial example
concerning an indifference we could be
ice cream
okay dude I'm at someone's house
and they offer me ice
taking no ice cream would be rude taking
two scoops of ice cream is two men yeah
so taking one scoop of ice cream would
be
for our solid the virtues yeah that
would seem to be in line with a stoic
account According to which
the sage makes choices in accordance
with nature yeah and nature is as it
were
um uh if you are a sage then the the
presentation or it's a fun fantasia of
one student shows itself as appropriate
Two Scoops is too many zero Scoops too
little yeah so even though to say being
a sage itself is not a matter of
you know it's not a matter of of a mean
between extremes yeah the sage will
choose the mean between two experience
the stoics would agree that the
appropriate Choice that's in accordance
with nature is in many cases somewhere
between too much and too little yeah
what I'm missing from the stomachs and
you can correct me if I'm wrong yeah is
our solo wants to say you know there are
there's Vegas
and what how big is the one scoop
yeah it is a little bit bigger than the
ice cream scoop a little bit smaller a
tablespoon a tablespoon and a half come
on
mathematical Precision yeah yeah and the
stoics seem not want to say if it's a
matter of choice
then there is a correct choice so if
you're choosing between using that ice
cream scoop and that one there is a
correct Choice there and if you mess up
it's the wrong answer I mean but they
have to mean somehow in this idea of
choosing in the context of a world that
gives you all kinds of Shades of Gray so
I'm not sure that the difference is a
stock as as they rhetorically make it
out to be
yeah I think and I'm sympathetic to that
I mean the stoics do say some weird
stuff about the sage like he never
screws up you know
um and not only does he have all these
virtues he's also like you know the best
in everything you know he's dialectical
he's he's erratic he's the best lover I
mean you read that and you're like
where the hell did they get these ideas
from you know and why and why would
intelligent people because they see a
lot of the other stuff they say is very
you know uh persuasive and intelligent
you're like why the hell would they
insist on this you know
um and I don't have a good answer for
that as to like in in real life
situations there will be choices I think
you're right the justice is going to
require you to take the right amount of
you know ice cream or
um you know should I the gas you're
staying at the place and and do you
insist on the couch or the guest bedroom
or things all these trivial things right
that the stoics call indifference they
they are measured and Prudence would
bear on those as well you know and I
think Temperance definitely would right
how much ice cream should I have well
maybe uh there's plenty of ice cream to
be had so each of us could have a gallon
but that's not good for me something
like that so I think you're I think
you're right about that another thing
too where I think this the stoics and
the aristotelians are not that different
from each other
so the Aristotelian mean
isn't just an arithmetic thing as you're
saying and there is vagueness to it but
there's also all these rights to it you
know the right person right time right
amount is only one of the host day or
you know how things ought to be there's
the right Manner and and all these other
things and I think what determines that
well right reason Aristotle says right
uh um so
the stomach say something similar orthos
logos is is doing the decision and
it strikes me that the stoics are unfair
to the aristotelians a lot of the time
um maybe polemically so maybe to make
themselves look better or make their own
position look more plausible
but I don't see them as as that
uh
opposed to each other when it comes to
practice like you're talking about it's
it's more of a theoretical position that
why the hell do they need to insist on
it so much I guess they really want to
stress
that
um even if we are improving we're still
we're still not where we ought to be but
Aristotle could say that too right or
Plato could say that too couldn't he
yeah it's like kind of a follow-up yeah
absolutely the still position reminds me
of uh ethical news
that bring in
the Divine as a moral Touchstone here
I'm thinking of two different things
yeah if you think about Plato in the
fatal yeah and of course the
neoplateness yeah
philosophical virtue involves a kind of
purification
assimilation yeah to
Eternal Perfection yeah
well if that's your standard just the
smallest tinge of impurity means that
it's not pure it's an all or nothing
thing yeah yeah yes there are stages of
some things are more impure than others
but if my water has the smallest drop of
salt the tiniest particles of salt yeah
it's not pure H2O if my soul has the
slightest tense of of uh connection or
longing for the material yeah I'm not
where I need to be
and then I think about the
casidic religious tradition we're going
to have an association where there are
three kinds of people
it was that Sonic who is the Holy person
there's the benoni who's in between and
there's the Russian who's the wicked
and that saw that like the soul of sage
never messes up yeah and there's a total
moral example
and I've got my problems with
identifying this person or that person
as a thought yeah but existentially it
makes sense because what does that mean
means I'm not it I've got work to do
even though I
I'm not as bad as you know this or that
person over there as long as you know
that you're not a not not where you need
to be yeah they're existentially there's
work to do so and that's an important
lesson to say I'm a pretty good guy
I'm doing all right
then that will make me lazy yeah so
maybe that's part of the appeal of the
counterintuitive stowed position you're
not there yet Greg neither am I yeah
don't rest on your walls
and so that seems to be part of what
Socrates is importing us to do in the
Fado as well you know we're we're not
there
um we we have work to do we need to keep
trying
to become more philosophical yeah
by setting up this
like likewise the nearfulness by setting
up this this
impractical ideal of total Purity and
assimilation to the one
it shows us that we're not there yeah it
doesn't mean we're horrible people
and that's it yeah if it isn't ideal
yeah but at least
we
we can't get too comfortable and so yeah
yeah no the stoics use the um the
rhetoric of your wicked yeah uh and
because you're not there and that might
be I agree with you that can be
psychologically unhelpful because in
that case why why do I even bother
you know it's interesting because one of
the reasons that I got drawn to this in
the first place had to do with Anselm
because ansum also has an Ethics where
there's there's there's virtues and the
virtues are don't have a mean in between
you know virtue and vice you're either
virtuous or you're vicious in a very
sort of stoic tinged Manner and
um you look at Anselm himself and he was
a really good guy you know and then you
read his prayers
um and his meditations and he's like oh
I'm so sinful you know uh John the
Baptist can't you help me out intercede
for me because I'm just a worm you know
and you're like is this is he like you
know doing false humility here and and I
thought about this for a while and I
talked about this with some benedictines
who thought about this for much longer
than I had and they're like no it's not
false humility the closer you get to God
um the more you realize all these like
places where what you thought you had
like figured out and you were good now
there there's all these pockets of like
crap that have to be have to be fixed
right and in a certain way so this if
this thing's an ideal it works much
better for people that have actually
Advanced quite a way because they're
emotionally mature enough to handle the
fact that they're they are still Wicked
in some sense although not as bad as
like those those people over there right
whereas if you were to like take
somebody off the street and you're like
all right we're doing stoicism today
here let me put all on the board you
know by the way you are as bad as the
worst person ever
they'd be like oh man this is this is
not helpful for me at all now I feel
depressed you know this doesn't conduce
to me making progress right
um so so maybe you have to be a certain
advancement along
before that that could be a helpful
ideal I mean it's funny because Cicero
takes the stoics to task over and over
again in his works and he likes the
stoics you know but he's like you people
really need to study rhetoric because
you do a terrible job in presenting your
doctrines
and I think he's completely right about
that you know you you make things more
more difficult not more complicated but
more difficult than they need to be for
people you know to to buy into
um so yeah I think I think that's
probably right yeah I mean one thing
that isn't there
in all this discussion is that is there
in the platonic tradition is that like
you know we're going to be like the gods
and and um
the stoics I mean they talk about a
commonwealth of gods and human beings
but we don't ever become like the gods
but if you're following nature you're
following suits yeah and following a cap
and the logos the big logos
that is God that's true is your logos
and they're totally in sync yeah but
you're gonna die and and you know you're
I mean materialist I mean Seneca Hedges
back and forth ah maybe the soul goes up
in the stars or something like that but
I don't think he really that's in
letters of consolation I don't think he
really buys that
um it's more like the aristotelians or
the epicureans you're dead that's it
whereas with the platonic tradition well
you've got this great possibility of
like living on and your soul gets
purified and you know you survive right
as a good person and you get to be like
in the faders friends with the gods
right
um
so yeah that's I think we I I took us
kind of far afield did you have any
questions or I did so do the Stokes have
a position on
like if a kid is born yeah are they you
because we discussed previously that you
know uh both there is a innate nature to
um some of the pillars of being virtuous
but there's also an innate nature to be
Wicked so is there like if a child is
born what's what's the story there
they're kind of all over the map okay
right
so Cicero in the account that
Cato presents
is you could say one tradition in this
where
there's actually like two tiers there's
there's the stuff that's according to
nature but even that isn't yet virtue
um we have these primary impulses of
Nature and they begin with childhood
right we have a we this is this is often
framed in terms of oikosis you know the
making things our own so you see this
discussed by by other stoic philosophers
as well
um like Heracles
so the idea is you get to a certain
point and then suddenly you start
recognizing something that's higher than
just our regular nature and
you you come to see that virtue is good
for its own sake right
um there's other accounts where I mean
they have the problem of evil right if
if we're
if our nature is good how the hell did
we get so screwed up right so they've
got like answers that are plausible like
well you know we're not fully rational
and we we find the lures of pleasure as
infants and get drawn into stuff and
then we have all these stupid adults who
are giving us bad examples you know like
telling us uh you you should be you know
you should be pursuing wealth and honors
and stuff like that
and uh you know the people who talk
about that sort of thing I think Seneca
talks about this it's sort of like well
no matter where you're born you're
probably going to have a bunch of you
know stupid family members that are
messing you up and you know you you
could think now there was you know Zeno
wrote a a republic right and there were
a few other political writings where
it's kind of utopian we don't really
know much about them we know more from
like detractors saying well they they're
they were for cannibalism or things like
that then we do you know specifically
but presumably if you were lucky enough
to be born into a household of
practicing stoics who are like the real
deal not just memorizing uh crucipus or
something but living it out then as a
little baby you could have like the
right kind of formation and they could
they could nip all the crap in the bud
that that doesn't make us like what we
are yeah so and the answer of time but
yeah something odd that occurred to me
is if you have if you can make choices
that are virtuous choices you can make
choices that are fish choices yeah yeah
but there are also many different
choices so theoretically yeah
in different choices no I don't I don't
think the stocks would say you could
um because you can't avoid
um
being in situations where you do have to
pick between what's virtuous or vicious
um I mean the things that the account is
indifference there are some things that
they say are like totally indifferent
like the number of stars in the sky or
the number of hairs on your head is it
is it odd or even it's one of those like
who cares right so um
yeah there is a virtuous Choice yeah
even if it is you know a relatively
minor exactly right yeah okay yeah
um
I mean why couldn't you say to The Host
ah you decide how many scoops I'm gonna
have I'll leave it up to you you know
and then you pass the buck on
wouldn't that be possible
sometimes hosts want to be more gracious
that is good for us
are you you're not making a vicious
choice I mean here's here's where like
again the stoic position right all all
bads are equally bad I mean I think all
of us would be like it's just an ice
cream I mean it does have to do with
like the virtue of hospitality and being
a good guest and things like that but
it's pretty minor it's not like walking
in with um oil on your your boots and
like walking into somebody's plush
carpet and then wiping them on there
that's more vicious yeah
and you can't just say you decide
at some point
that's a good one yeah I like that
uh we had a question though um yeah
well
you raised so many
part of one of the things I was going to
ask about but another thing is
I find it very hard to make sense of the
these arguments without knowing more
specifically what virtue consists in I
mean at the beginning you said you want
to avoid that yeah on the other hand I
mean for example I just use one one
aspect of this
um in your quote from the from Seneca
letter 74 you talk about sometimes
virtue is widespread governing kingdoms
see
creating wall s developing friendships
and regulating duties that hold between
relatives and children
Etc okay it makes it sound like
like people can be virtuous on the other
hand then you have this other extreme in
which it sounds like virtue is just
about impossible if indeed it's ever
been found yeah have there been any
sages have there ever been
Etc yeah a lot of the you're trying to
understand this depends on
knowing what virtue consistent you can't
it's very hard to do it to make sense of
it yes arguments without getting into
that
well I mean that's where the other
things in stock text would be useful I
mean areas data mess gives like a whole
breakdown of the stoic virtues
um Seneca does it a number of different
points I mean there are the four
cardinal virtues right and they'll talk
quite a bit about like what what's
required at this in this kind of
situation what what's involved in this
sort of situation Sister Rose on on
duties too you know book one is a
breakdown of the stoic virtues because
he's basically copying pen atheists on
duties as well but yeah I mean when it
comes to that that Passage
seneca's point is not to try to tell us
precisely what virtue is there he's
trying to say listen virtue can be
extended to all sorts of things if
anybody happens to be virtuous you know
um is virtually the same thing in all
these cases is there a difference for
example comparable to Aristotle's
difference between moral virtue and
intellectual virtue oh okay yeah so the
stoics don't recognize that difference
right
um
and even with Aristotle it's kind of
unclear whether Prudence really is just
an intellectual virtue because it's so
tied in with the the moral virtues
so I mean they do have again in areas
didymus the stoics will talk and also in
diogenes they will talk about other
things that are virtues but not moral
virtues
um like dialectic is a virtue right but
we don't actually have enough of what
they say to figure out what what
precisely they're talking about there
compared to the the moral virtues
um but I think you know between Seneca
and
these summaries of stoic Doctrine we get
a pretty robust conception of what each
of those virtues
wisdom Justice Temperance courage does
consist in
um they don't they don't look I mean
with Seneca you do get a little bit of
semi Aristotelian you know it's not it's
not foolhardy it's not cowardly it's
right in in the right amount
um and then there's lots of examples
that they'll give too the
the problem is whether they lead you to
the point of saying
that it's All or Nothing
oh those don't those those discussions
of the virtues don't lead you to that
that's a separate Doctrine that's the
problem because then yeah it's hard to
make sense to begin with with the notion
that it's All or Nothing
I don't I don't see the the
incompatibility there I think that
you're seeing
I just don't buy that they're all or
nothing
you know
i i find I find the other arguments that
this can't really be the case that
there's like you know this dividing line
and you're either on this side or this
side and it's like you know moral
progress doesn't really mean anything
that can't possibly I'm insisting on
them
say that again
yeah
and and you wonder why you know in some
cases but it but again we're this is
where we're kind of handicapped I mean
if we could have um precipice's ethical
problems
we we might resolve a lot of this stuff
we might be oh this is exactly what they
were referring to
but all we've got are these little
um
citations
um again you know I mean I doubt that
we're going to get anything out of
herculine am that pertains to stoic
stuff but we can hope you know
Zeno had a whole I mean Xeno Clancy's
crucifus get brought up all the time and
each of them wrote a lot of things
having to do specifically with with
these moral doctrines
and we just don't we don't have more
than fragments you know unfortunately
so yeah
oh we're we're getting probably close to
time yeah so so thank you for stopping
yeah thanks for the question thank you
very much uh Greg and uh this will be uh
both on our Midwest seminar page and on
YouTube